I was born in this overall house right
next to the Union Baptist Church in
plateau Mobile Alabama in this house
my grandmother had told us a lot about
this history but being a little girl I
didn't know that this history was as
important as it is they wanted us to
remember that our family came over on
the Clothilde Atalaya slaves they made a
bit down on the mobile docks that they
could bring this year unseen and on her
because they knew it wasn't either
it was a racist deep and victimized 111
people from beneath and brought them
here with the intent of enslaving them
[Music]
they wanted to make sure nobody's name
was connected so when they burnt that
ship they said no parts of it was left
[Music]
there's a very powerful defendant
community right here in Mobile Alabama
called Africa town they're trying to
reclaim a memory and reclaim identity
and replaying culture they started
Africa town with a meek and humble begin
they wanted to make this their Africa
they wanted everything right here this
community at one time was
self-sustaining had barber shops grocery
stores cleaners everything that you
needed
we had fruit trees everywhere everybody
had chickens and Gardens there was
always something cooked at somebody's
house and they cooked on what stoves
Africa town was family everyone looked
out for each other it was a place where
we had pride when I start to talk about
Africa town sometimes I get a little
emotional because it's nothing like when
I grew up
up until the late fifties Africa town
was his own incorporated area but mobile
began to cool Africa town and in the 60s
the city rezone from residential to
heavy industry because they want to get
those taxes from those industries so I
can understand our people in the area
feeling as if they have been forgotten
because they were just like the
bulldozers everything in here moves
2,000 people out and just just
industrialized the rest of it they
figured to ignore you and just let your
house fire down your people die off and
buy off your land then that's what they
do
[Music]
[Applause]
when I first came to after town I met
the congregation I found out that just
about the area family has someone that
they knew or was in fact about cancer
most of the people who were sick who
have been the ones that was playing in
this suit in this ass that was falling
from the smokestacks of the industry
around when you look around it's a
dilapidated homes no one has put any
dollars to open up a store that's why
the hope is gone there's been economic
tragedies there's been environmental
tragedies horrific extent but their
folks who are holding on
now after they able to go down and parts
of that ship maybe now it'll be document
s last spaceship this mission is it's
about again doing the comprehensive
search of all the vessels that's in the
stretch of the river
by chance we want to follow something of
interest that would be great
six-inch iron spike and that was on the
wood okay okay are you going down are
you going up okay
feels all wood okay
[Music]
identifying a shipwreck is a difficult
business we look at what the
craftsmanship suggests to us there's one
target in particular that stands out
it's roughly the same size as close to
eighty six feet long and 23 feet wide
according to its registration documents
frames evoke as well as planks of
southern yellow pine fasteners all made
of iron we haven't seen a single
fastener yet made of copper or brass
[Music]
we've got a ship of the right size and
what we think is the right place at this
stage where we're at this could be
clotilda vessel is located it's gonna be
a very powerful artifact the office tell
the story we think that would be one of
the most historic finds in America not
just in Africa the whole story becomes
life and becomes truth it's not a new
chapter you know from their perspective
you can present many many opportunities
for them people are get excited about
the community to rebuild it to give it
his promise now we are have the proof
that we need to know that we will part
of the is Bill Mobile we need to tell it
we need to share it we need to expose it
to the world
if you people will listen to me from my
heart operate on you there will play
wave all the breeze bring our boys back
home see but we are
[Music]
[Applause]